c'est ici que george leslie makaay a
trouvé sa vocation transformer taïwan
qu'il a tenté mais il est débarqué sur
les berges de la rivière dans le chou et
il ya 150 ans offre aux qualités et
c'est non loin de là qu'il a fondé la
première université de taiwan en 1882
explique fièrement un des responsables
de l'université alethia nouveau nom de
ce qui était appelé à l'origine le
collège offre e norme sata tirée par
marielle nous voulons répandre l'esprit
du révérend moka est dit il il prenait
soin de tous il voulait améliorer leur
sort
sur le campus la demeure du docteur
makaay a été transformée en musée des
artefacts et photos ornent les anciens
salons rappel des soins dentaires
prodigués à des dizaines de milliers de
taiwanais en plus de la fondation d'une
soixantaine l'église
est là au deuxième étage se trouvait la
salle de lecture et d'écriture du
docteur makaay l'endroit où tant de
projets sont nés sur l'ailé
conservatrice de l'époque le révérend
makaay a fondé la première école pour
filles les premiers pas vers
l'émancipation et l'égalité le fils de
george michael lui a poursuivi l'oeuvre
de son père en fondant une école qui a
formé un bon nombre de politiciens et
taiwan est important le modeste hôpital
fondé en 1880 par le révérend moka y est
aujourd'hui devenu un vaste réseau de
pitau maillon important du réseau de la
santé de taiwan as tu as one si
différent des autres missionnaires le
révérend makaay a marié une taïwanaise
il parlait le mandarin ce qui a facilité
son intégration et qui lui a permit
d'évangéliser davantage de personnes
dans ce petit restaurant on prépare un
bep spécial à base de brocolis choux
carottes et fèves vertes le repas du
docteur makaay
après tout si ça son héritage
explique-t-il makaay a apporté des
semences et nous avons pu découvrir ces
légumes qui n'existaient pas ici sinon
la hauteur en tête pour l'intendance
c'est une histoire qu'il aime raconter
aux clients de la cérémonie du thé c'est
sa façon à lui de promouvoir la culture
de son quartier historique
originaire de l'ontario george leslie
maca est mort à 57 ans d'un cancer de la
gorge il a été enterré avec sa famille
tout près des lieux historiques qu'il a
fondée à taïwan un timbre commémoratif a
été émis pour souligner les 150 ans de
l'arrivée du docteur makaay taiwan veux
rendre hommage à son héritage qui a
façonné ce qui est devenu lille il si
philippe leblanc radio canada taipei